según el Gobierno Federal de Australia
el uso recreativo de los vapeadores es
la nueva amenaza contra la salud pública
del país pues inicialmente se presentó
ante gobiernos y comunidades de todo el
mundo como un producto terapéutico para
ayudar a los fumadores a dejar de fumar
pero ahora se ha convertido en un
producto dirigido a jóvenes que en
muchos casos son menores de edad cifras
oficiales reveladas por el ministro de
salud Mark batler indican que uno de
cada seis adolescentes australianos de
entre 14 y 17 años y uno de cada cuatro
jóvenes de entre 18 y 24 años ha vapeado
en los últimos 12 meses La Línea Directa
de venenos del estado de Victoria ha
recibido 50 llamadas sobre niños menores
de 4 años que ingirieron vaporizadores
se han encontrado hasta 200 sustancias
en estos líquidos incluyendo químicos
utilizados comúnmente en quitaesmaltes
de uñas y en herbicidas por eso el
gobierno anunció este proyecto de ley
que busca restringir estos productos
únicamente a tratamientos terapéuticos y
prohibir la importación de vapeadores de
un lo uso además se restringirá la
concentración de nicotina los colores y
los Sabores su venta ya no será
permitida en el comercio sino únicamente
en Farmacias con receta médica y sus
empaques serán similares a los que
tienen los medicamentos e incluirán
advertencias de salud la mayoría de los
vaporizadores contienen altas cantidades
de nicotina según el gobierno
australiano los efectos a corto plazo
del vapeo pueden incluir un mayor riesgo
de infecciones pulmonares asma y
enfermedades cardíacas Y un sistema
inmunológico debilitado la venta de
vaporizadores sin receta se prohibió en
Australia a finales de 2021 pero no ha
sido suficiente para frenar la
importación ilegal a través del mercado
negro por eso ahora el gobierno Espera
que el parlamento apruebe este aumento
en las restricciones